back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
ready bro bro I guess I am let me put my
keys in my pocket oh yeah I'm ready for
him I put mine on the ground dude you do
yeah you uh fresh back from New York and
you're rockin the old FDNY tee huh yeah
I get that Fire Department kisses a fire
you know who to call
well yeah you don't want to [ __ ] it up
and order pizza you know you got to call
fire department yes but it's good that I
can call the New York Fire Department
when you're in LA hopefully that oh dude
they come they care they're the best
their noses best didn't you see 9/11 do
the they're the best bro you're right
you ever seen backdraft huh you're
seeing backdraft
yeah war is that filmed I think
Philadelphia yeah half the people died
so good but not as good as New York Fire
Department you kind of look like you're
in backdraft really his Mel Gibson
backdrop with that mullet you know Tom
out
I look like Mull Gibson you know and
this is an Impala 3:30 Lipson what this
isn't a mullet as a hockey haircuts dude
was that Mel Gibson back after my off
huh my off right now I don't know dude
you look like something that Drake keeps
on his keychain today brother what are
you drinking a cup noodles no dude they
don't have any cup so I tossed out the
[ __ ] noodles in this thing turned to
a coffee cup holla holla making chicken
[ __ ] in a chicken suit baby that's what
we call where I come from really yeah
where did you come from dude knows dude
Wow
New York was good to you though huh
Janey in New York was cool man
um what happened oh I had a couple of
different shows good shows Caroline's
the show's not my favorite club man it's
okay it's just like a chop shop you know
it's like I'm sorry Caroline's once you
do Gotham or like just I'd never done
Caroline's or Gramercy Theater yeah next
time I'll do something different this is
just you know I just I don't know I
wanted to do it cuz I never been there I
think trying to like hurry like we had
you know meet-and-greet after they try
to hurry the people through and stuff
he's made me kind of upset yeah so and
then yeah like did you meet some like I
started the
no I'm just complaining now but look it
was grateful to everybody came out it
was good
you look like [ __ ] man let's get back to
that can we you look like [ __ ] dude I
cried in there's a fire department okay
you're sure doesn't look like [ __ ] you
look like yeah well this is Who I am
worth Jonas brother who got caught in a
microwave yeah
you like Jonas dirt yeah three sexy ones
and you just got [ __ ] melted in the
microwave I look like no Jonas you look
like what bro
what I look like man damn the steam from
that coffees making your CTD flare up
dude I don't know where I'm at right now
I just saw your eyebrows kind of [ __ ]
try to [ __ ] get off of your head
they're looking for help where were you
at man this weekend yeah I don't know
anymore really
owes my girl's birthday oh it's my
girl's birthday bro oh it sounds
miserable yeah I mean actually it sounds
beautiful man she's a beautiful lady and
no I don't try cover now I'm with you
man but they suck especially after
therapy how they do after 30 it's like
what are we doing do you really need a
gift every year every year what is this
what is this actually here we have to do
this yeah it's like somebody's like oh
like Santa's stopping by in his off time
just to give you something you know I
guess it does feel a little Randy
doesn't feel a little like it's getting
old it's just an old kind of tradition
like after 16 let's stop giving gifts
yeah yeah like don't you know what else
don't text me well my brother can text
me don't text me during holidays yeah of
course dude of course I want you to have
a Merry Christmas I need you text that
yeah Happy Thanksgiving
[ __ ] off dude yeah with my family dude
yeah I don't need some yeah some chick I
met in a trap house or something four
years ago to send me a you know god is
good today yeah I don't need that or
happy Easter when you suck me off in
Cleveland seven years ago this is the
Lord's Day Ramadan and your [ __ ] hey
good luck with your fasting okay well
not Muslim yeah you know I'm saying
Oh Ramadan I'll hit everybody up on
Ramadan - and I just send a picture of
food
yeah what happy Ramada dude because
Ramada Inn be a shout out I'm Spence
don't toast me bro don't toast me
brother do not touch me do a toasty dude
let's touch feet hey totally is this huh
what's this contraption cuz to be a
little scared of it
we got a random black box we're in
America
today's culture dangerous dangerous to
put the on but well this might have been
that Malaysian flight maybe this thing
fell out of that Malaysian flight baby
bro
it's the black box but that's our new
buzzer they never found it I don't think
they still have it here it is I said
Elon Musk if you were a real wizard he
[ __ ] find it but he's over here
making [ __ ] ask garages in the
ground in subway system yeah dude
get my ass bro do you want me to turn it
up yet turn it on man whatever whoa okay
let me let me do that again okay God it
sounds like uh let me see you know
lesbian who tell her I'm here the voice
again I want to try to figure out it is
might be Johnny Cash it's pretty nice
alright is it nice I'm doing a little
volume on that you ready yeah so if we
want to clean it up a little bit King it
little gang gang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who is that bro that sounds very
gameofthrones II don't tell me anything
bro I'm on the episode 7 of the first
season do not tell me anything
Joffrey a vicious boy 7 Joffrey you [ __ ]
boy unbelievable dude who does Joffrey's
hair you think bro stand from that
Eminem letter God [ __ ] is [ __ ] up yeah
it's like that kind of violent it's like
it's that angry lesbian kind of a bit of
the beep when he was younger though is
it yeah that Ellen be lesbian oh yeah I
remember when Ellen and the beaver
crossed hair pads yeah that remember
they switch did like a Freaky Friday
yeah yeah but they looked exactly the
same that's crazy
worked out for both of them yeah that's
true I'm both I'm we're doing well yeah
that's a good point who can dance better
though Bieber Bieber Ellen 61 yeah it's
not really my gram every time I saw her
broke out in a dance my bitching is stop
let's start the show
yeah what a boys what up dog how much
Derek good to see someone who knows what
they're talking about
yeah it's good to see some with an
opinion yeah and good a season with a
dope ass haircut Frederick Derek Willis
[Music]
and finally even though we asked last
week we got pictures of Derek and cat
guys you can see them if you have it on
YouTube yep we're putting a move yeah
dough
yeah so your idea Elon Musk II that's it
man musketeer over here Elon Musk it
fire dude thanks boys ain't gang going
to pay to booze you know Theo one thing
that people don't mess around with is
dogs people love their dogs we love dogs
your dog's health is as important as
every member of your family if not more
important you know yeah I also I reason
I have dysplasia in my hips and you know
who gets that dogs Australian Shepherds
dogs in general too though yeah you know
what what are you feeding your dog do
you even know what's in that food you
don't that's your best friend you feed
your best friend weird food no you're
not man you're not use Ollie all he puts
dogs first with a vet formulated recipes
and fully transparent ingredients to
give your dog the healthiest food
on planet earth yep oli got beautiful
items imagine something going into your
dog now imagine it's tainted food you
don't want that oli won't let that
happen because they create customized
vet formulated recipes made with
all-natural ingredients no preservatives
you never seen a dog out in the in the
woods sucking on a couple chunks of
preservatives this is the source best
friend it's your best friend best friend
y'all this is your Huck fan man and you
don't give your Huck Finn a bunch of
junk
never never food
Ollie's food is sourced from fresh farm
yeah that's right and they beat the in
store-bought dog foods that's right they
beat it man yeah because they create the
best food you can get go to my alley
that's my o ll i e dot-com answer a few
questions about your pup to customize
your recipes for your dog your best
friend and the ship the food to you guys
and I'll tell you they've delivered five
million meals and Counting shipping is
free and if your dog or el perro doesn't
like the meals no me gusta el desayuno
they have a money back guarantee Papa
yeah so if your dogs complain to them to
shut up always offering our listeners
60% off your first box plus a free bag
of treats at my all e.com slash try
slash cats that's right this is the best
deal it is it's the best deal they have
available anywhere go to my alley my oh
l li e dot-com slash try TR y / k 80s
for 60% off + off free bag of treats
free free bag of treats
that's my alley comm slash try slash
cats time to buy few more pants a Theo
did you know 66% of men lose their hair
by age 35 no I didn't know that and you
didn't even know it I didn't know it
either because look at us dude both of
us got to worry about our hair run dry
Brow's oh he's about to touch your ass
crack not really the stuff isn't for you
what I'm about to tell you not for you
it's for guys like my brother who's
losing their hair who Jay Chou yeah it's
guys like Bryan Callen father time is
cutting their hair you know I'm saying
oh there's guys like that man so if
you're like that don't wait cuz when you
wait it's too late yeah you don't want
to go bald man I'm talking about four
hems use four hems dot-com a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin kill and sexual
wellness yeah that's the thing here's
the thing as some things are facing men
you know front and center and it used to
be you know war and you know business
and Vietnam and stuff but now it
fighting father time it's fighting
father time man he's got a mother thing
you gotta sharpen your sword and show up
with some real Valyrian steel show up
with that dick game so how you do that
is with four hems Don right dude a
well-known generic equivalents get sent
to your house that's right no snake oil
pills no gas station counter supplements
none of them talk about real stuff man
prescriptive solutions backed by science
no waiting room no awkward in-person
visits to the doctor you know just save
hours by going to forums calm it's easy
it's a few questions a real doctor looks
at prescribes it boom sent to your door
hit him with a deal Theo
I'll hit them with a deal order now and
our listeners here on the podcast get a
trial month of hymns you know what I'm
saying bring a little bit of boy
Theodore for just five dollars today
right now while supplies last see the
website for full details and safety
information this would cost hundreds if
you went to the doctor or pharmacy go to
four hems fo r hims dot-com /k ATS
that's fo r h-i-m s.com /k 80s for hims
comm slash cats get them hims trying to
keep lights on startled us dude let's go
King understand it today our first one
is from Norm Schmitt from Tel Aviv
Israel oh wow now I'm out here norm from
Tel Aviv he's a no no is no one
dear when Brandon this is your boy
Smitty oh they got you straight out of
Tel Aviv Israel that's right from the
[ __ ] Holy Land man oh [ __ ]
watching me son
oh my anyway got teenager stinging for
you guys burnin Shabbat I recently went
to see that new that New Avengers movie
which is dope by the way and I went to
go see it alone I went by myself reason
I went by myself is cousin I don't know
none of my friends schedule schedules
with like schedules mine so I just went
to see it when I'm Marvel movie drops
I'm going to watch that [ __ ]
gang bro yeah so anyway my King
understand for you guys is uh what do
you think about going to the movies by
yourself King it or sting it let me know
and just for the record I'm not the guy
sitting in the back jerking off right
I'm sitting front and center and I'm
watching a moment time over respect
problem myself yeah buzz real hero like
Ned Stark or gnome stark right there yes
and bro shout out to be here with
Brennan Shabbat I saw pretty [ __ ] out
but uh yeah man sit in the front if you
gonna jerk off dude don't be a little
wiener you know sit I'll be upfront
about it soon get arrested yeah bro you
know what yourself some raisinettes and
jackoff yeah I don't know who the
Avenger I mean I know that Captain
America is in there but also whoever
else brah mighty Fauntleroy whoever the
[ __ ] the Avengers are get up there and
jerk off with the best of them beat the
world you know what I'm saying shoutout
it Tel Aviv sounds like you have some
busy friends if he doesn't know their
schedule maybe just text and see if
they're available to hang out for the
movie but they don't have text in the
Holy Land
how will you send a pigeon yeah if to
send a pigeon or a raven if the paint no
raven white and [ __ ] tell them it's
like it or they just pray on it and hope
movie times work out in that crazy in
the olden days for like two because a
raven a dove was expensive so they
they'd whiten up a raven and they don't
really not like at weddings and stuff
Raven yeah because you get a raven easy
they would sammy sosa the ravens exactly
so so raven
let's dough do that is ro and then they
also at some point in time in history of
time they had on because then you would
just kill something the Ravens would
show up they're easy to get doves today
get them the rats of the sky baby no oh
yeah agent you idiot I mean you're nice
you're right dude hamsters are the
[ __ ] doves of this guy no hamsters or
land animals dude the ground no I know
but if you're but they're the if you
know you don't know how gravity works
yeah you don't know let's move on no
thank you wait well answer his question
what's he to go tomorrow movies by self
grown-up man I saw a stranger a pet
detective Rowan up human this week no I
my mama and miss Q I saw it six days in
a row by myself I was a grown man with a
kid can't be going by myself anymore
little weird but when I was younger I
just be super gangster about it go all
the time by myself King that [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] your friend's house Jack no new
friends well look now I must say that
that you know a lot of time it's
basically you're just auditioning for
virtual reality when you go to movie by
yourself you know you're just making us
see if it's possible from one day to you
to be completely enclosed in a place
where you'll know everyone's schedules
you can put on a VR you'll know
everyone's schedules you know a fair
you'll stop by and say hey T right in
front of you if you wanted to or
whatever you know maybe a truck full of
fresh apples will just capsize right
next to you and you'll have a view
possible virtual reality your audition
for that right now brother so I think
you're doing well also you're in the
Gaza Strip dude you might never even see
this video you could have you know
called a bomb to the jaw right now or a
rhino
I just want do a rock yeah just that's
what they do over there the rocks
oh dude you've seen the videos both them
and holders bro brother Palestinians a
[ __ ] they got a lease issue on the
land so they're figuring it out do so if
you're still alive gnomes shout out brah
be saying out to that dude man see
whatever you can while you're alive
brother dude but also don't waste time
trying to get a girl and take her to the
movies get one of them cyber bots yeah
yeah dude you're a living halfway
virtual just get a girl yeah get a robot
dude dude get a robot you're sexy man
you're in Israel Bronstein he's Jewish
dude who else [ __ ] uh Larry David
Larry David in a sitcom get a robot fran
drescher now definitely do
and some Jewish women can be really
[ __ ] angry so you might out again
yeah make it numb up yeah funny movie
yeah [ __ ] that guy yeah there you go
gang bruh up next this is uh this is
just for King adore sing it huh
this for life dude that thing's awesome
mine always is sad
well no you got to reach over like it's
a simple look it's about 1/2 an inch you
just gonna hit that dude J mustard
mustard
seems like somebody just shot a t-shirt
at me at a [ __ ] horrible Charlotte
Hornets game let's go Nick this is from
Jeff trainer this videos from Jeff
trainer JT hey guys chitty-chitty Gang
Gang chitty-chitty it could be a new
thing to Chitty Bang Bang no jingler
stinging yeah please don't owls
what do you think Bryan Callen if you
know any
dude that's Bryan Talon you could rip
his drip for all I care subin's drip for
all I care dude [ __ ] talents
chitty-chitty dude he looks just like it
yeah they look like and look they've
been smoking weed is on that Bob
Marley's one love Wow can you lose balls
deep in that how roll back just so we
have the owl end scene there please
Derek beautiful new dude look at that
thing's [ __ ] dinosaur claws
I do trust ours brought a that right
look like an owl a little bit I think
you do look at tad like a now yeah you
get the same no slanted eyes same nose
yeah like we just put your note down a
tad you get the same nose same chest
hair same body not body yeah feet kind
of not on same body they're similar
shoulder-width
I don't trust [ __ ] house man this the
thing anything that can turn its head
360 degrees I'm out I can dude you know
I'll do that
ya can't ya do asking you I don't trust
them bro I don't trust [ __ ] house
I don't trust people who own owls but I
like this guy do
I don't [ __ ] trust a guy who dresses
like grimace from San Quentin okay but I
still show up to work with him every day
owls dude killed that woman in that
movie uh that documentary the staircase
um have you seen that or not - that's
the conspiracy yeah that guy that killed
his wife blamed it on [ __ ] owls and
they took the blue wives too much yeah
they got it killed - Wow
you know what I believe bro this is a
nice owl I've eaten some [ __ ] shitty
al in my sister's house on Thanksgiving
here's what you don't know about owls
not as much meat on them as you'd expect
they look meaty you take off the jacket
the fur coat they're basically the
praying man don't reverse of the animal
kingdom take off the fur coat brought a
[ __ ] Nate you know pretty flimsy very
little meat like opening a new bag of
[ __ ] Pringles you know I'm saying
there's not much going in about half
full yeah it's like cracking open aa you
know a fresh thing of avocados from
Mexico when they got a lean Latino boy
in there you know yeah not enough
avocados not enough meat is what we're
seeing on the boat dirty bro so I'll say
this anybody some some places owls need
to go down some places they're
endangered I don't trust him bro I do
not trust him it's neighborhood to
neighborhood dude you know dude they had
a now when I was young picked up my
buddies little sister no joke and lifted
her probably maybe 18 inches off the
ground still though it's impressive I
don't [ __ ] trust him anything I turn
its head 360 demon demon animal that's
the devil's work that's the Satan's bird
you know they can drink milk out of a
cow yeah I didn't know that there used
to be videos of it I don't know they
kill each other yeah they do they're
[ __ ] now was broke yeah dude what do
you think if he saw an owl and you are a
now you're gonna let that other one live
dude most famous Al though huh most
famous owl what do you think Al Gore
look him up Al Gore yeah better the
Internet no here you go how about the AL
from [ __ ] the Tootsie Roll the
Tootsie Pop Oh - stupid I [ __ ] hate
that thing since I was a kid that little
outside Muppet dude blue outside she's
all high all the time trying to educate
kids how many times it takes to lick
them [ __ ] tootsie roll how you ever
licked a tootsie roll 3000 likes to get
that goddamn Center yeah man [ __ ]
dude first of all if you licking that
bro you might as well find a woman by
the time you get to 770 licks some you
know some thought is gonna come by and
you know squirt in your mouth what why
do you say that dude why would you say
that man conversation about owls yeah we
were having a nice conversation dude why
would you ever say they're spitballing
ideas here man oh we're spitballing
ideas you're disgusting that owls
discussed in do ya deflect the blame you
Creek I like the guy [ __ ] is al well
obviously Brendan they look exactly the
same by the way is a dirt ball and I'll
say this buddy and I think this I think
I know this guy I think this dude you is
my friend Tim's actually roommate they
used to live in Baton Rouge over tear
off a Highland he clicked Alice nobody
looked like that guy actually this guy
looks a lot stronger actually I don't
know this I guess shred City yeah I've
never met this guy but he looks like he
sleeps with the elves I bet Isles are
pretty cuddly first of all Al's dude
mailmen in Hogwarts
so obviously doing good [ __ ] anybody
that can transcend universes and go from
you know realm to realm like that it's
dark arts Al's or dark arts I know they
are you know this yeah do the Bhaskar
know you're talking man to come in my
mouth like you all do no I'm not either
dude I'll sound like the face
the cartoon into no t-shirts you idiot
so people say you're disgusted hey first
of all if you're hustling Al's that
those they're [ __ ] expensive I'm
saying the meat on any cheap man you
don't buy it you get it you kill them
yeah you have enough owls around you
okay and if you have enough owls around
you dude there's nothing good going on
so gun a couple down or use a lasso but
I love them brother and thank you for
looking here one that and thanks for
some in one of the dopest videos we've
done with a live a Sal bro they're God's
ubers dude and they send messages from
the from the nether world straight to us
no they're Satan's post mate yeah you
can't trust it out bro that's the
overall theme of that whole thing man
you know nothing in your IRA [ __ ] dude
and you'll die early here's an ad from
the king of the sting yo you know the
king of sting gear sold out fast and
people like dang we got our stuff so
fast and so nice yeah that's right man
cuz we're using shipstation oh yeah when
you're selling online you're getting
your orders out there can be a beast man
but not with shipstation not anymore
it's the fastest easiest most affordable
way to manage and ship your orders hit
them deal oh you could ship a fart to a
Falcon with this company dude you can do
whatever you want ship station gets the
job done it helps you get your orders
out quickly save money on shipping costs
and keep your customers happy and no
matter what you're selling if you're
selling through Amazon Etsy your own
website ship station brings all your
orders into one simple interface make it
easy make it real these ship station
works with all the major carriers
including USPS FedEx UPS Amazon ever
heard of them yeah wonder ship station
is the number one choice of online
sellers that's right right now King and
the sting listeners can try ship station
free for 60 days that's 60 days of
shipping ship ship ship ship when you
use promo code K ATS there's absolutely
no risk if you think there's risk
there's not you can start your free
trial without even entering your credit
card info well
ship away ship station comm cook on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in cats that's K 80s that ship
station calm the enter promo code cat
ship station yeah make ship happen
you'll be like Magellan man ship ship
yourself ship someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit right now we got
a relationship advice yeah whatever yeah
I'm sorry
the first one is from Tyler meta Tyler
data now Tyler meta I'm gonna send you
to live out there by the iron castle
what a deal would have bringing Tyler
from Kingsburg California Central Valley
working the fields boy gang boy you know
I got some relationship advice for you
me and my girlfriend of two years he's
recently broke up you know she goes to
college about a few hours away I'm over
here working two jobs all the stress and
distance kind of got to us mm-hmm but we
still love each other just now another
time well you know she's my person I
really want a wife rep but I don't know
what to do should I just move on just
forget about her or just wait for her so
let me know guys gang gang buzzbuzz
buzzbuzz little lover bird very
beautiful story here and this is very
over I've read this book and this is
John Steinbeck wrote this story and this
man is working in the strawberry fields
down there in uh near Salinas give him a
little strawberry fields forever and his
girlfriend's out there getting caught up
getting learned out you know she's
getting laid out all right whoa guy this
is the love of his life Oh backpack full
of books yes that's awesome yeah yeah
the books going on study guide you feel
on a books some study guide named uh
Laval dress some study guy named Daryl
oh no where does Jackie know just kiddin
man she's definitely touching anyone in
college no and she's out there I think
what you do is you got to take that
sabbatical man you got to take that
little break from your lady I think you
give her some space man I think you sent
her a shitload of strawberries well look
I mean every day oh I think you sent her
something once in a while keep her you
know keep her fuller just make sure she
always has you in her mouth a little bit
yeah yeah send her now keep your
companies have an owl spy on her in
college we got we know a guy
oh yeah we do know a guy we just met
this guy white guy a Bob Marley fan who
was either actually had an owl or was so
high he made us believe yet an owl or
were and it was [ __ ] stuffed toy our
bundy did I did see it I did see it put
one of its hands in his pants like that
and try and sell some women's shoes yeah
get out of here buck
so with this dude man there's nothing
wrong with taking a little break if
that's your person go for it dude
go for a brother yes it's also good
thinking about breaking experiment oh
dude gain some experience free just jump
on in for life he's young as [ __ ] keep
picking them strawberries pick up a
couple house on the way and then when
she graduates you got four years of this
bro you know and four years save the
money pick the strawberries get your
dicks ugh and then after four years you
guys reunite you got a pet out shitload
of strawberry he's in the hot Sun you
guys can't hear on the audio Bay I mean
the videos from he's out in the fields
basically doing the damn thing this guy
is I said a hair on him too yeah I mean
he's a very handsome young man he's very
uh I could see him in westeros be honest
with you I like that [ __ ] shout out to
engine 96 ladder 54 that Bronx you know
what I'm saying
end of story that's what they say dude
sometimes you gonna let the fire burn
run somebody gonna let it sizzle out and
show back up later you know when
everybody and just get you rescue you
girl out the ashes you know you can be
that rescue rabbit and so something you
know your girls out there and you know
they you know she's the world's chewing
on her she's a carrot and in a little
while bro she's gonna be all kind of
chewed up and you're gonna [ __ ] sneak
in there that rescue rabbit with them
frescas maybe win the juicer baby with
them strawberries you know juicer like a
carrot or she's a dragon queen she's on
fire dude yeah fire but that you don't
burn show up with a hose brush up with
two pails of water in three years and
[ __ ] quench her thirst from whoa
hopefully in three years don't show up
she's with a guy named rag nice [ __ ]
shred City it looks way better than you
let's not do that
yeah but cut him in the chest with a
knife you know died about a week LASIK
Dao on him good brother
yeah man it sounds like yeah it'd be
patient man you know I'm saying don't
don't do anything unless you really
really
don't do it if you just think it Brock
you're gonna ruin it you taught my
desperation dude least a few cars if you
catch my drift
Oh before you buy one Lise Lise Lise
then you buy and for you yeah hop on a
line brother Thank You Birds take a
couple uber yeah up next we got Lauren
from Nebraska this is she sounds cute
those eyebrows are nice Oh different
then we go sup guys this is Lauren from
Nebraska one of my best friends even
about growing up the hair you know it's
getting kind of long here
beautify growing it out I want to get a
mullet you know that Louisiana Purchase
I feel you baby
yes rocking the Osama bin Laden he lets
cut that dog with a muff tickler oh my
god I don't think life for that
white-trash for Rory I'm trying to
figure out how I should convince her
otherwise you know anyways love you guys
let me know what you think Gang Gang
buzz-buzz dude his eyes my brother
[ __ ] I'm in a trance
oh my handsome dude obviously I tell
them in the club yeah sure yeah buy you
a salad somewhere I'll buy you a [ __ ]
I'll split a donut with you in the trunk
of your car yeah this guy definitely
could be JonBenet Ramsay and hiding
there this guy dude look at the eyes
look at the skin tone yeah transition
baby other side I could see that man now
this guy look man you got the beard you
got that deal bro
don't let the lady determine how you
want to grow your hair bro you can't
just listen to the lady boss you around
thank you okay we'll give him some
suggestions guys here you give him some
suggestion because you actually have a
moment but this isn't a mullet first of
all there's a long man's male haircut
you mean you know you gotta cut around
the ears though dude yeah I'm gonna cut
around the ears again dude we're as soon
as I get back into the hair shop and do
do what you want okay yeah I mean right
now I feel like you look like heroes
like some Rouge on or some blush on
oh he's got bullish on dude his eyebrows
are ridiculously trimmed
yeah dude are you sure you have a wife
dude yeah dude you sure someone's tell
me not to do it are you looking for
deals approval here yeah you're just
looking for two men to talk to you about
your hair I think you're just fine I
think you already know what you want to
do yeah dude I mean you look very well
taken care of and at a certain point a
beard is just transporting lice bro okay
just basically you have the Underground
Railroad for head lice hanging under
your chin so if you bring that near a
girl surprise bro they're so dirty [ __ ]
they're so dirty oh dude I was on a bus
in Tucson one time when I was in sure I
don't know some part of school and this
dude had a little a little kind of
holder built into his beard and he had a
[ __ ] little bird in there Oh tight
moved oh that's cool is it now mm-hmm
it was just like a homeless guys bird
eat some easy to get I think I lost
stupid Birds no just bear around Birds
yeah basic Rambo Sparrow is probably a
nightingale um anyway man I think if you
want to grow a mullet grow a mullet dude
but it's also not even a mullet man you
got it you know you know you it takes
rocks to grow to locs baby you know what
I'm saying you got to have balls to drop
the falls son you just can't do it man
you just can't get that hate crime on
the back of your neck and think
everything's will be all gravy yeah yeah
I would yellow you gotta ease into it
bro just don't shave the sides you look
like a [ __ ] white supremacist what
you got to do is style the top grow the
top out and then get the feel in the
back yeah maybe braids it broke Brady at
first see how it goes over at the homies
but this is the rebellion dude this is
the [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
you're growing your own you like this is
the thing your wife says you can't do it
and then you grow it yeah that's what it
is that's that MTV and early 90s that
rebellion man it's not it's about you
doing you you know what I'm saying it's
not about you being held down by a [ __ ]
barber with a [ __ ] a1 into a2 with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] fade you know and he
gots the [ __ ] in there and the
magazines and all of that and [ __ ]
here's the other thing though it's also
the first step to transition it yeah so
if you're gonna shave the sighs leave
the back next thing you know you got
tits transient so you know put a little
Rouge on the lips next thing you know
you got some mascara on next you know
you're wearing your wife's skirt you
know I'm say hey Lee
yeah that's how it starts with mullets
bro no I've never seen any of that all
I've seen is a sheer warrior [ __ ]
grow out of my heart
that's all I've seen so you grow the
hair first and the rest you will follow
son yeah maybe they letting your wife
determine what you [ __ ] hang you
don't come out of here you know what
we better get a video next week with you
a [ __ ] mullet have you know courage
boy hi there him brother you know
courage boy oh you know what ethnicity
she is though cuz if she's Mexican
they're [ __ ] spicy man she's Puerto
Rican I get it bro I'll send you to be
one of the Lord Frey's daughters dude
out there you better look like [ __ ]
deer ma jagger next week bro yeah yeah
yeah Jesus Christ and obviously that is
the name that had burn and drop out of
school when Jaromir Jagr you know who
that came one of the most famous hockey
players here for the Pittsburgh pink oh
[ __ ] don't touch me dude you're just
gonna grow your [ __ ] out don't ask your
wife if you can plant Jennison y'all do
it and when you come home say shut up
that's God's backyard brother and he
gave it Heatley he lent you a little bit
you're just sharecropping so won't you
ask God what he wants you to do sorry
man I'm a little fired up em no you
should be bro you should be but it is
that's what's goin on man a real man we
grow it out dude
you know rumor wouldn't even ask ya
better see a video next week with you
the full-blown [ __ ] hillbilly mullet
brah
yeah up next we got rip my drip Met Gala
edition boys let's see whose ass [ __ ]
some people like Riddick oh yeah right
start with a little hairy stars it's for
the Mets they are hopefully Benny
Agbayani they're shut out like by Ani oh
my god is that Mark Wahlberg Harry
Styles ooh
Macy Wahlberg I don't know who the [ __ ]
it's very strange man when fashion goes
this far it's not gone this far this is
not appealing to me at all
this guy looks like strange to do this
like think about going up to a stylist
in like here's what we're gonna do this
year are you out your goddamn mind
I think the stylist is telling them but
it's just getting very Rome and like
it's very Shakespearean at a certain
point you turn into you start dressing
like a woman then you're dating an older
man like once you've done everything
there's this Roman
there's this Roman ladder in the world
where once you've you know you have as
much money and power and then you you
know you quit dating women and you start
you're in threesomes foursomes nine sums
in your history dude yeah and then you
start sitting remand and they get their
degree it's very great Roman you can see
styles going down that ladder right now
you know just very much fault like if
some stylist told him this is good man
I mean this guy like you know these
stylists Holly was turning all these
guys in a little sugar babies I make
sure you're just dating older men
playing music for them and their gay
buddies yep
that's it man they pay the bills bro
that's your future Harry it is a hot tub
Sinatra that's all you are then up there
in them Hollywood Hills they're nice
jewel dude yeah ask jewel where she at
stood in the rain you're always crazy
like that that jewel is that yeah what's
jewels most famous songs from my doorway
there's nothing to see besides some
comment oh no whoa no some handicap girl
played out of my high school one time
did it that's at the talent festival or
whatever night right talent festival you
document oh yeah tell it festival it was
a festival in our towns we had some
[ __ ] Sears talented Von D but I cried
you so much you're in the song when I
got up to walk out I slipped on my own
tears and fell down damn it was that
good oh yeah it moved you that much
stood in the rain - I don't know that
song dude you all know you know this one
who will save your soul eyes at your toe
boy yeah that's the Jim I'm a dog an ya
know something on öhlins ever knew I
could for her though yeah jewel that's
what she became a sugar baby because
she'll Hollywood
eat her up and you know spit her out oh
it's what happened man but yeah it was
that again Hilary Duff got a haircut
what happened Harry Styles Harry Styles
bro dude won't you let your stepdad
style you for a freaking half hour
hearing no Styles get the [ __ ] out of
here bro yeah do want you put oh yeah
you look like you dressed up like a
Christmas stocking
[ __ ] you look like one of princes
[ __ ] dick
you know warmers yeah I mean what do you
even wear him bro that thing can't even
stop the wind bro dude just could you
put on a dress don't tell us it's
fashion bro people doing this for years
yeah dude you look like somebody ordered
a couple of chocolate [ __ ] at a
Benihana you bring out the dessert man
cuz my man tighten up but god damn
domain Jared Leto
he's my spirit animal Wow oh and he has
[ __ ] what's his name oh no is this
he's the new Aladdin he's Jasmine from
Aladdin that's what's going on is he
really yep I think that's odd that's the
inspiration dude this is not fast and
all he's wearing is a turtleneck and a
woman's dress he looks like Michael
Jackson was going to look if he had been
alive for a couple more years a little
more sir a little more advanced and
[ __ ] yeah surgery he would have been
looking like this it looked like Michael
Jackson if he was on that show um gold
hunters what does that show where they
look for gold in the hills but the Oh
what is that nugget boys or whatever
gold nugget boys the 14 nugget thoughts
or whatever yells brush gold rush yeah
uh dude think how much of a narcissist
you have to be to go you know what I'm
gonna do this year I'm gonna have to
make an expensive head and we carried on
the [ __ ] red carpet dude that's
what's-his-name the frickin Instagram
prophet the guy I've already loves him
who's a comedian oh no you're talking
about
salt Bay that he killed salt Bay that
ain't that's so baby no he killed salt
baby kitties on the red carpet now that
makes sense
oh that's ballin he's still my spirit
animal dude I love Jared Leto salt baby
that's salt bay bro no it's the guy the
comedian who dated Katy Perry Oh Russell
Brand Brad yeah yeah yeah looks like
salt Bay to me though
really that's insane he became salt Bay
now realize you can't even see out of
your own eyes give me a pistol brand huh
9,000 percent more than salt Bay dude
how about all the [ __ ] jewels
well here's the sad thing though he
probably has some little thought or some
little buddy carry the head
no heels the parties and you're that
[ __ ] bring your own head you got to
carry the head partying carrying Jared's
head man remember match me that guy I
know damn but I'm kind of bummed we
didn't get invited me to was your
address though I feel like we to wear
dresses here's Robert a warm puppy nice
a Dorian coat just a green coat yeah
something like the Masters you know hmm
I don't know if that make it on the
carpet yeah it would just a green coat I
mean everybody likes golf would think of
his dog just put a little Rouge on you
yeah this guy looks like uh you know
it's like he's [ __ ] Jasmine from Aladdin
and you know what I dig it
really that's my boy bro he looked he
looks like he went to just Jared Leto I
mean this looks like the [ __ ] jacket
is jewelry ever bro that's ridiculous
dude
yeah and what else you got very much
looks like Michael Jackson I'm in a bad
mood today man you notice that I'm in a
bad mood too are you why I don't know
why I think it's the owl no that was the
best part
yeah you're right dude and I was
beautiful man do you know what we should
be happier cuz they out
yeah we need something to lift us up you
have any let's get a new categories
making those categories we got you have
any Laffy Taffy to make me happy no I'm
sorry brother but we can do a little way
better dead Oh fine I'll mind a little
pink starburst and wet better dad do
some way better dad man next episode we
have a brand new category another were
coming out with it's my favorite see how
you wouldn't shut up about it
oh my god what's that Brad King what's
that Francois bunion good coup 420 here
my three nominations for wet bed or dead
are Roseanne Rosie O'Donnell Barbara
Walters unless she already dead didn't
question if so alternate Melissa
McCarthy let me know and if you haven't
guessed it already kind of a chubby
chaser anyways gangbang buzz cuz
[Laughter]
I wanna say shout out this job bro he
has murdered 17 people yep and that's J
Saab dude dude oh very nice to see him
dude ro but it was it rose damn Rosie
O'Donnell and Joe Rogan Oh Barbara
Walters I'll kill all of them really
yeah I'll go straight up with you I
would mayor would I would I would
probably marry rose in cuz it would be
fun oh I would bang Barbara Walters and
I would till Rosie O'Donnell and Rosie
O'Donnell I would he could marry her
Duke and they could talk about that
[ __ ] movie that I love we are members
of the all-american League we come from
cities near and far we're cousins or I
wish em were more we're all for one
American what's that game big league was
called oh my god that is a calm you
idiot what is it bad kids weren't any
good at baseball shoes leave their own
that's right that would be your favorite
movie makes a lot of sense big league
was always the thing that the kid who
wasn't any good hadn't had it at
baseball there were they were two tails
tobacco two kids on the baseball team
where I can playing the shortstop and
the second baseman and the first baseman
those the only three kids were playing
the other day if you were in centerfield
no one can hit it that far so you never
play I was in no would you laugh no one
could know get out there yeah so they
put the shitty kids in [ __ ] deep left
I was in centerfield dude I remember one
point I was just telling people where to
park as they kind of parked out there
yeah I was way out there one time I
didn't want some mushrooms out there
they were just growing I was deep left
the game is over
dude you could chill with Barbara
Walters and just have fun with the way
she says words and [ __ ] Wow Rosie
O'Donnell looks like the UH that big
king that got killed
oh he talked him about a king Ralph no
the Game of Thrones King Oh Lannister no
Ned Stark the guy oh I'm gonna drink all
the wine that's a head start bro
yeah he looks like she looks like Robert
Baratheon very much so can we pull a
picture already
you look almost identical yes she seems
upset all the time very much so I feel
like she would be yeah it'd be rough to
hang out with her Rosie yeah yeah well
she just you know she was posed to move
to Europe after the election that she
never did
so milling around talking all that [ __ ]
nice stuck here yeah now you [ __ ]
stuck this up what up baby or similar
very similar there you go dude I want to
hang out with any of them [ __ ] I'll
kill all them damn brother
no chivalry zero don't wanna hang out
with a very similar huh like a young
Robert Baratheon hormones she could
easily grow that beard my that was a
good impersonation him almost almost
spot-on yeah yeah all you do oh you're
all you ever talked about was people
[ __ ] yeah he is custom he looked like
a guy used to own a roller Kingdom and
then it went under are you at the point
where he dies yeah he still talks about
I hit the point where yeah yes I heard
that spoiler dude I don't want to have
to pick out of any of these I guess I'll
marry Barbara Walters okay he said you'd
marry Walters he'd kill the rest I'm
already put my name Walters not the same
haircut so I would obviously make love
to her and Roseanne Barr dude you know I
think she's probably one of America's
top 30 women I think you know people
love or as an one of the best ever
yeah still is you know a City know she's
touring a little bit right now in what
city she started what Denver bro Comedy
Works that's what she got to start she
had three kids working as a waitress um
do sets at the Comedy Works in Denver
yeah Beast
yeah she uh dude I love Roseanne uh if I
could do uh sitcom
I'm what I would do one with Roseanne
but that's I'm trying to get in touch
with her and see if she would so you
don't sound desperate at all you'll
figure it out yeah well look at Robert
Baratheon right there do you should do a
sitcom with Barbara Walters really yeah
due to sitcom brawl jerk off in front of
that lady oh that's a felony sorry this
is getting out of here this next this
sucks
up next is Nate from Albuquerque
come on neighboring a some bring it dog
well you know I love single moms table
with data black widow in a heartbeat man
so I marry a black widow Oh Lady
Oh and that lady just seems out of place
in that outfit yes you don't seem like
you're fits does it did she steal
Captain America's outfit is that what's
going on here
yeah I see the movie yeah it seemed like
just oh who is this little vulture who's
this Red Robin vulture damn boy they
want to eat it Red Robin you feel any
better you broke them [ __ ] mistake
fried a lot of beautiful baby birds
there snake fire yeah they do
dude how do you know all this junk food
if you're supposed to be like an athlete
or like a hero or something you said it
I guess I'll be your hero dude Hey
to quote Tony Robbins I'm not your guru
bro I know [ __ ] restaurant food man
yeah but you sitting like a Marie
Callender's link a couple to the hate
really hey I think it was that hey
they're going out of business cuz all
they sell is [ __ ] pie since 2019
listen Thanksgiving Christmas sure I
want apple pie outside that keep the
[ __ ] out of my face man I'm leaving hide
in the middle summer do you see what
your sales are so low you are just angry
guy yeah I am today man for a guy oh oh
dude you got me fired up about pies are
you taking kratom in the kitchen and
we'll put that video at the front of
this whole episode cuz I caught you out
there you did caster doing some drug you
and chin I like the buzz that chin had
that Korean dust
I think it's sweat and he [ __ ] just
oh dude he definitely looks like a
lifeguard at a sweat lodge first of all
what the
look dude be honest with you I probably
jerk off to all of these chicks and then
just stay at home and watch something
[Applause]
Scarlett Johansson she dresses Colin
Johanns yeah and the black dude she
ingests up where the [ __ ] she wants I'm
on board with her the girl in the middle
is trying too hard you're not captain
Miller get the [ __ ] in my face
Little Red Robin knight on the right all
right cool I'm down for all three you
don't say yeah looks like trapped in
America this girl looks like a girl that
works at a trap house and she like
guards the back door you know but the
girl on the right red rocket or whatever
her name is saundra I would date her and
the girl in the left Scarlett Johansson
thought that was April from ah no that's
a good point
she's a dope-ass April but uh beautiful
I love them all and they seem like good
women to me I love them I don't kill any
of them well the one in the middle is
just more of a drawing so I'd like to
see an actual picture of the woman you
can wait idea though you know I'm saying
you did have those dope-ass thanos rings
on when she came to the premiere she's
looking pretty tasty she was I didn't
see that so I'll admit that give you a
bone the one on the right is dressed
very much like a vampire and I like that
you know it doesn't make sense does it
the rest of them are superheroes she's
kind of more of interview with the
vampire yeah I'm more of a [ __ ] blade
vibe right a little dark yeah it's a
little dark she can get what do you
think Derek I'm tired of hearing Brendan
I'm tired of [ __ ] her and CEO tried
to stumble through this episode New York
did you hit the train what happened
Skaar Jojo see me where the [ __ ] she
wants she'd be [ __ ] punking Jack from
yeah Nightmare Before Christmas if she's
a black widow dude she's definitely in
Whiteface today so I'd love to see her
actually show up this is probably a role
that Will Smith is doing now you know
they got him playing a blue guy in 16
wasn't everything dude but is it real
though is it believable
him as a blue guy yeah cuz I believe
Robin Williams you did oh yeah good
point and maybe he'll do fine I haven't
seen it is it out yet let's not hate on
it yet that's true that's real let's
give it a shot don't hate on the man
you're right man I'm saying we're not
we're not haters
yeah that's true we do you think you
maybe maybe if you got a little blood
flow in your lower
cheer you up you wanna show you pick
some porn or something oh dude that's
explains we're in a bad mood dude it
busted the mojo I'm just tired man I
just wished that I had just a nice pool
or something the nice did I gonna pull
out the crib come over after climbing
out there you gotta wear a hairnet but
swim around cat yeah swim around yeah
where'd you leave your shirt on around
my kid in a hairnet but swim around they
have a lifeguard out there no you're
looking at him really no bro if you hire
a lifeguard oh come I'm not coming out
there if just you by the pool my kid a
savior well we didn't get it what did
you get an idea or something just can't
even focus for like 30 minutes
dude I got cannonball just hanging out
the bottom I can see that dude that's a
CT flare up dude you ever noticed that
paramedics [ __ ] rescue every time I
thought they're just friends giving
mouth-to-mouth
yeah no dude it's really gone astray
Derek say something get a debate club
how about that yes wrap it up
the first one is from Trey from
Pittsburgh Trey way
Pittsburgh dude the Monongahela boy got
them Stewie eyes confluence Oh Shelley
pardon Boston Massachusetts
my name is Justin is my bro Stephen
we're just wondering we're gonna have a
little debate ourselves Tupac or biggie
think my intentions of the rod rod rod
rod rod rod you know any biggie songs
dude before we lose sooner man I'm
honored lose Oh fat little Kim going to
prison that's all you got but it was all
a dream
come on dude it was all a dream
you too reader to read Word Up Magazine
some pepper on my on my peen okay we
don't know the song he's doing but you
know what they're both dead nope so no
no
they're both dead so listen do Park in a
[ __ ] heartbeat brah
really - part 3 part 4 part 5 part
island island island island dairy let's
go to Derrick first let's feel like yeah
worst of all - cated then you on racket
let's go to the yeah let's get some
people crazy the culture corner with
Derrick and catapulter corn with Derrick
and cat I'm gonna say biggie all day cuz
smoothness you know me - buck always
sound like he's gonna fight you you know
what I'm a nurse didn't like that he
always kind of aggressive you also know
Tupac went to Juilliard so it's going
slow your gangster down yeah oh yeah
yeah I like Tupac biggie is better
lyrically but I grew up with you walk so
didn't we all did it my own inner kid
the one who bought the theater kid he's
a straight theatre kid yeah that had a
tattoo of thug life on his tummy so not
very thuggy yeah what was the biggest
thug you ever played he was in a fellow
wasn't he yeah he was dude he was he's
also in Peter Pan I'm saying if I have
to pick I don't know
you know what ruins it for biggie for me
was [ __ ] P Diddy just ya nuts for a
little bit dude maybe not Ryder dude
that's all he did all open the videos
when there's all this talent yeah I'm
the P Diddy of comedy like I'm just like
you're biggie I'm solid yeah I have no
business being here but I'm like in the
jumpsuit all up in your video you are
that's all dude yeah but P Diddy you're
right man who know I don't know how I
mean P Diddy seem like the dark arts a
little bit he's almost like that like
the person like you know you kind of
wonder what he's up to how I even got
manage his way through it all and he's
the only row dance moves he is the
whitest [ __ ] dance moves ever it
always look like he kind of dropped
something and then remember him in mace
huh
marry him in mace how did those two
navigate their lives like remember the
rap video where they're both didn't
[ __ ] shimmery [ __ ] velcro sooo
yeah and it's you know that video which
one is it it was so epic but you're
watching like how did these two get a
[ __ ] music video
they're like bumping in each other both
have [ __ ] CT
neither doing the [ __ ] Harlem shake
yeah no yeah dude so but now but then he
must be the best businessman he's just a
champion he's a champion businessman or
the people he works with are and also
men I hear he party you know he's I
don't know man did he's got to be there
must be something really amazing about
him I was at a gym one time in Hollywood
and they kicked everybody out cuz he
came in with his crew no way
and I would you do you hid under the
water no I refused to leave and they let
me stay yeah I bawled me for the rest of
the time
dude that's come on to the house that's
crazy get them towels what is it 1870 do
they seem like the most racial thing am
I gonna call me white boy
oh my dumb towels you got them towels
mm-hmm and then I drove them around for
the rest of the day dude when I used to
go to on Louisiana State they had um you
know this was silk to shock or a see
murder huh to come and play hoops and
masturbate mr. cow oh do this to cow
dude I [ __ ] saw Mystikal doing coke
at a car wash of course she did
the hot boys oh dude here's the thing
Master P would show up right this is
when he was trying to get on a Charlotte
Hornets right never happened but he yeah
sure no bro so he would show up Silkk
the Shocker was there see murder was
there they were all playing hoops they
would play at the rec center and they
had these dudes that were dressed up
like in all these gold chains and
everything who would stand on the side
with their arms straight out and hold
their like towel and their extra shoes
and clothes like in their arms like this
man do you remember Silkk the Shocker at
that that big ass hit what was his hit
Silkk the Shocker you got the biggest
hit man I remember I wasn't fully murder
killed a couple guys and then they let
him out of jail and he's like I wanna
know what I'll do kill someone in the
back face let me out no you're being
ethical bro free mystical prison he went
back he got out and made a hit song and
then right back Silkk the Shocker had
that [ __ ] oh it ain't my fault it ain't
my fault
yeah this girl's big-ass hit the
mystical had a bunch of heads dude
thought mystical nobody the hot boys huh
y'all is ain't ready yet I don't know it
was hits man oh you have to rape charge
in the working with watched oh here I go
yeah oh that's right that's about it
yep that there's two of them that's cool
yeah man that's it though all right gang
bro he's in prison now for rape so you
know you still made the hit stop yeah no
rape buddy you don't do that kind of
stuff you got to tighten up mr. cool
yeah not so hot anymore are you boys
yeah
53% of people said Tupac gang now who
died earlier who died first
ah Tupac died and then Biggie died so
that's interesting inside in a 2-bike
died in like Vegas biggie died here Wow
everyone thinks the CI a [ __ ] a
then what's the consensus in the in the
cultural community guys you guys are
Vietnamese and I think it depends on
what city you're in and Derek if you're
anywhere the middle of the country this
way people can say Tupac Miller country
that way I think huh it's you think it
gets regional I think it's rude here's
the other thing though is P Diddy still
I won't shut the [ __ ] up about biggie so
it's always in our face ain't no one
really reppin Tupac is yeah good night
Jeff [ __ ] he ran over three guys like
some are wall someone give him a Slurpee
so he killed all three and I thought no
one would notice in 2018 we all watched
this dude thank God we still got your
wolf boy feel me Trump music vol 3 out
now let's roll bro let's get get me out
of this way from Theo dude
next [ __ ] did I'll do that it ain't my
fault
dena meter you keep bumping me against
the world this is a nasty tto that's
little job that's a little John who's
basically is pretty much P Diddy's long
haired brother to the window that's a
dirty song this was I don't watch I
don't listen all that heat ski from the
window to the wall
you're disgust all my [ __ ] crawl
right what do you got Nick Springer it's
from Nick what up D I'm Brandon mrs.
Nick come to you from Sacramento this is
Zach town the breakfast variety go with
Captain Crunch mmm oh no you did it this
is a good one now you get now you got my
blood Thank You Sophie and her man for
chiming in hit it Brendan what do you
think I'm a captain crunch all
[ __ ] day I love not the berries
hate the berries though just the crunch
dude I haven't had them in a hot second
here's the prom with Captain Crunch
gonna stick in your teeth for about
three to four days yeah and it [ __ ] up
your gums too man teeth it's like meth
yes delicious yeah it's basically a
little meth nuggets you know it's
basically trapped in crunch because it
gets trapped all up in you in you in you
and it'll eat your teeth out Jesus
Christ rap rap one of your molars in a
nine Captain Crunch chunks they track
and truth the beyond two days later
hunch zero tooth dude is very very
dangerous and the captain where's he
from captain or what do you know I'm
saying dressed up like one of Michael
Jackson's little [ __ ] dick nugget
dressed up like a muppet remember him
remember that captain oh yeah that's
weird
Baltimore what diabetes brother dudes
bringing in some straight bull [ __ ] all
aboard cavities captain yeah Captain
Crunch is a dark artist working for the
dentist and you know that and so you got
to know that going into it now what is
the other one cinnamon toast crunch sit
him into his groans a fat chef that was
[ __ ] hustlin yeah weird now it's what
it's the Keebler elves or something or
in it or is it the dragon is it the rice
krispies no it's the rice krispies
these guys they're doing now did they
switch it up cinnamon toast contra I
thought they couldn't do cartoons with
sugary cereals anymore can you look up
Derek cinnamon toast crunch and to see
what comes up now they're terrified is
it is it the elves I thought it was a
fan okay who knows kids see really do
you know that you don't have to can't
see him anymore I mean that dumbass bird
oh he's pitching them [ __ ] [ __ ] Froot
Loops beautiful animal beautiful animal
[ __ ] personal animals are out of work if
you click on the boxes say anything can
him know they're gone dude they can't
advertise it anymore Wow it's tally yeah
it used to be the chef remember yeah no
it's a no it's a it's just eyes on that
on there yeah heard they can't do
cartoon characters I'm see robots
anymore because the kids are so drawn to
and it's terrible for you sugar is dude
uh once in two weeks it's good I went
two weeks off a sugar dude and
everything started tasting sweet I'm
like dude there's sugar in you know some
perfume and cologne has sugar in it yeah
I sprayed in my mouth so I guess sweet
teeth really would say sweet tooth I got
a sweet [ __ ] mouth really I'm
addicted to sugar since I was a kid oh
you seem like a sweet little [ __ ] what
I'm saying is this brother all day I
would go with I don't you know what I'll
be honest with you I go with Captain
Crunch because it's a little less sugary
and I go with the low sugar variety bruh
specially as an adult I'm a grown adult
you know I'm legally an adult you look
like you got to eat raisin bran [ __ ]
that dude I have had raisin bran dude
and I've also had cracklin oat bran
which is very expensive you're out you
where was it wheat know uh shredded
shredded wheat no I mean I remember the
rump you do I'm gonna lose shredded
wheat when it came in just the one big
one you know yeah you're gonna [ __ ] your
pants oh did you hit a sister that fiber
hitter that brick fiber hitter the first
time I had so much fiber dude
they had like everything came out of my
body everything urine tears do not piss
the whole cry into the toilet
everything expelled from my body we're
gonna hit me with I'm gonna hit you with
sugar smack so the Frog no one's heard
that you [ __ ] Sugar Smacks that's a yeah
it was a gold bag you don't put up this
a goal I don't crazy
circa sex with the Frog oh yeah have you
heard of it or not dare love them and
you open up it's like a [ __ ] oh here
it's like that frog a little we gonna
hit me with them I'm gonna hit you with
what was the moment this is grow and the
raisin nugget clusters not honey bunches
both what was it
anybody raising clusters look at that
Sugar Smacks squirrel let's look at him
oh that's a frog bro maybe cuz they both
have the Hat on they were kind of they
laugh this a little bit they laugh the
same yeah the same tongue and Honey
Smacks looks like some Derek would say
or have written on his tombstone if you
ever died oh you know honey snacks baby
hey honey smacks bro Derek can express
come on you don't worries that it looks
like a nickname his mom calls him
sometimes well honey Selena's mom be who
she wants kisses from give me some honey
Samaras Magnus come on baby
hey I got my free uh-huh you look like
the mascot for her fruity pebbles bro
yeah [ __ ] those work good God they were
[ __ ] good god damn it this you know
it pisses me off they're so good dude I
would eat all the green ones and try and
decide if they actually tasted lime or
not and they did didn't they
no really I felt like the limes tasted
different they all tasted like sugar do
Oh
I'll hit your dumb ass with this you
ever had the Lucky Charms and what they
do is they'll put a salt & straw off a
[ __ ] habit Kimmy they take ice cream
and they make just the marshmallows out
of hell what are we doing that's living
brother is it living do you some I got
my dick hole it's so good Oh Oh God see
we can hit me with your vulgar you know
what's it you're right dude I'm gonna
trumpet you can't you it oh the squirrel
with the nut clusters yeah raisin row
not clusters will you look at there's no
clusters bro I know my cereals you talk
about honey bunches oh no I'm not Utah
oh honey nut cheerios honey bunches with
that stupid bee no buzz buzz baby that's
it honey my clusters honey nut clusters
dude yeah you got me there remember the
[ __ ] squirrel and the commercial
would come out and he'd always be like
looking for
to do or whatever no I don't whatever
dish I must have been in Louisiana TV we
don't even bother
dude you remember the [ __ ] Cookie
Crisp there yes dude with the burglar my
dad would give me those dad don't give
me [ __ ] 70 cookies with milk before
school bro there's a reason why I'm
addicted to sugar now every morning gave
me [ __ ] those look cookie crisps your
father gave you life he'll give you it
every once dammit are you [ __ ] mad I
be a [ __ ] honey my veins all the
goddamn face the sword you little twink
God you all the cereals and the best
came up with [ __ ] honey nut clusters
you live on the Iron Islands out there
with the Greyjoy's you little once you
get to touch your sister's tits on a
horseback creep get me out of this
episode get me the [ __ ] out of here dude
educate yourself on serial to do serial
I'm an adult who's trying to live their
life can I'm just sitting there gonna go
to the science wing of the library and
look up cereal predicted opposite said
Cinnamon Toast Crunch and that's it boys
six and percent of who pedophiles dude
yeah kids voting they don't know [ __ ]
bro dude we should call this the angry
episode
stay away from this thanks for the
buzzer 2 News yeah whoever what's a
dude's name who made it be Mattie Maggie
oh he's a rapper too shout - Mattie Mac
dude this thing's dope Mattie man
dropping them fresh ass lines man keep
keep up the good fight bro yeah yeah
whatever Brennan said dude get me out of
here see guys love you yeah it's like
that British TV show give me the [ __ ]
out of this woods I'm being Cleveland
though you are yeah oh and Brahman
Cleveland really yeah Cleveland
hilarities I'm uh very end of the month
- June first
get your [ __ ] tickets I'm not even
telling you buddy went out of here I'm
gonna get me out of here
you get out of here get out of here get
out